today's video is sponsored by our
friends over at keeps do you know that
two out of every three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
trust me i know that i wish keeps been
around when i was younger because
advancements in science meant that there
are now treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss
and help you keep the hair that you have
it's too late for me
my hair's not coming back you don't have
to be like me you can stop your hair
loss early thanks to keeps keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda approved drugs for treating hair
loss so you might have tried
them before but never at a price this
low that's right
if you were thinking well this is some
sort of medicine thing so it's gonna be
mad
expensive simon well don't worry it's
not keep starts at just ten dollars a
month
so how does it work well for one thing
there's no need to visit a doctor's
office just schedule a quick online
consult and a bit later a
discreet package will arrive at your
door and then you can use it in the
privacy of your own home so if you're
noticing that you're losing your hair
it's not going to fix itself go to
keeps.com forward slash biographics or
click the link in the description below
to receive 50 of your first order and
let's get on with today's video
at 6pm on april 4th 1968 patrolman
richmond of the memphis police
department was
at his observation post inside a fire
station on south main street the
african-american undercover officer had
been instructed to keep an eye on dr
martin luther king jr the civil rights
activist was in town to support and
direct a strike of sanitation workers
richmond could clearly see the reverend
as he stood on the balcony
of his room at the lorraine motel and
then
came the shot
a police tactical squad had just stopped
at the fire station for a break richmond
came
running to them telling them that king
had just been shot some of the tactical
team ran to the lorraine witnesses
reported that the shot had come from a
red brick building on south main street
just across the road other patrolmen
immediately ran there to inspect the
area
one of them found a blue suitcase in a
box containing a rifle outside the
canopy amusement company
at 424 south main street a witness said
it had been dropped just a few minutes
earlier by a sharply dressed white male
shortly afterward a white mustang had
left the area at high speed
at 705 pm dr king was pronounced dead at
st joseph's hospital
a bullet had torn the major blood
vessels in his neck on the way in
then severed his spinal cord on the way
out the fbi immediately declared this to
be a top investigative priority
investigators traced the origin of the
shot to the rooming house owned by
mrs bessie brewer at 422 south main
street she reported that
john willard had registered on the 4th
of april between 3 and 3 30 pm
he had rejected his first drew moving
into another one which faced the
lorraine mattel willards was
approximately 35 years old 5 foot 11
with a neat appearance charles stevens a
guest at the house was staying in a room
next to willard's that afternoon he had
heard someone occupying the bathroom on
that floor for a long time without
sounds of running water
or toilets flushing when he heard the
loud bang of a gunshot he looked in the
hallway and saw a man running with a
large bundle under his arm a few minutes
later a man matching willard's
description had dropped the bundle
outside the canopy amusement company
this bundle contained a model 760
remington game master rifle
a scope and a blue zipper back in the
bag was a pair of binoculars and a
receipt proving that they had been
bought at
york arms company in memphis that very
day the fbi was able to trace the rifle
to aero marine supply company in
birmingham alabama on march 29 a man
named harvey lomair had bought the rifle
and a scope he had then exchanged the
original weapon with the 760 on the
following day
he claimed that he needed a more
powerful weapon to hunt deer the fbi
also
combed through the hotel and motel
reservations in memphis they found that
on the 3rd of april an eric starvo
gold had registered at the rebel motel
in memphis
this man matched the description of john
willard and drove a white mustang
agents found that gold had bought a
mustang in august of 1967 listing a home
address in birmingham alabama while
inquiring about galt in birmingham
agents learned that
he had an interest in dancing and on
april the 11th police found an abandoned
white mustang in atlanta
it was gold's of course by searching the
car they found it had been serviced in
los angeles
out west the fbi started probing dancing
schools and gold's name popped up in the
records of the national dance studio
here the
owner mentioned that gold had an
interest in becoming a barman
investigators found an international
school of bard ending in the area and
they struck gold
eric gult had indeed attended its
courses and there was even a photo of
his graduation meanwhile
agents in atlanta searched throughout
low-cost rooming houses looking for any
evidence that
gold may have been staying there he had
indeed registered in one of them on the
24th of march
in his room agents found a map of
atlanta someone had circled the house of
reverend king in the headquarters of his
civil rights organization
the southern christian leadership
conference further clues proved that
golt had returned to atlanta on the day
after the assassination but the trail
stopped there luckily the fbi was able
to recover three fingerprints from the
binoculars and the rifle thanks to their
extensive database on april the 19th
they found a match the man known as eric
starbo gold was identified
by his real name a known criminal and
prison escapee by the name
of james earl ray
james el rey was born on the 10th of
march 1928 in one of the poorest and
roughest neighborhoods in alton illinois
he was the first charge of
george speedy ray and his wife lucille
better known as seal
for the first six years of james's life
speedy tried to live honestly but
opportunities were scarce when james
turned seven speedy was arrested for
forgery once freon bond he
moved the whole family to ewing missouri
life kept piling misery upon the race
in the spring of 1937 one of their
daughters marjorie died in a fire the
tragedy tightened the bond between james
and his younger brothers
john and jerry the three would always
remain close in adult life helping each
other through hard times
it was with john in fact that james
experienced his first arrest when he was
just 14
for selling stolen newspapers at the age
of 15 james spent most of his free time
with his uncle earl who introduced him
to
the world of all night bars brothels
gambling and brawling
after uncle earl was arrested in late
1943 james decided to leave ewing and
move back to alton
staying with his maternal grandmother
mary mayer the teenager took a job at a
shoe factory staying out of trouble
during this period he
hung out with his young uncle willie
meyer and his co-worker henry stum
stun a german american did not hide his
admiration for hitler in the nazi party
uncle willie later confirmed to the fbi
that james's friend was an individual
who had pro-nazi leanings and ray became
anti-negro and anti-jewish as a result
ironically james and stun worked at a
factory that supplied the us army in its
fight against the nazis in europe
at the end of the war the military
suspended orders from the factory and
james was laid off
somewhat counterintuitively james joined
those who were responsible for his
firing
the u.s army
in early 1946 james earned a marksman
qualification at camp crowder missouri
and was transferred to
bremerhaven in germany the deployment
was not a positive experience
rey came face to face with the
desperation of the german people living
among the rubble of bombed-out cities
he came to sympathize with the neo-nazi
werewolves who ambushed the allied
troops but his german period is marked
by petty crime
james dealt an army-issued cigarette
selling them to civilians or
trading them for black market goods
during his deployment and well until
1948 james began drinking heavily
according to his brother john james also
experimented with drugs
mostly amphetamines his superiors
eventually took notice and in october
1948 ray was charged with being drunk in
quarters three days later he escaped and
was briefly awol before being captured
the army had had enough and so
rey was dishonorably discharged in
december of 1948. after a vagabond
period ray was arrested for burglary in
los
angeles in october of 1949. this would
be the start of a recurring pattern of
burglaries and incarcerations
[Music]
rey's patton was briefly interrupted by
two years of relative stability in
chicago
there he worked several factory jobs
attending evening school and even dated
a girl but it didn't last
on may 6 1952 ray tried to rob a taxi at
gunpoint
upon release in march of 1954 he learned
that his family was disintegrating john
and jerry were in jail speedy had left
seal for good and
some of his younger siblings had been
institutionalized the way that james r
ray saw it
there wasn't much else to do but
returned to his fledgling life of crime
in march of 1955 ray burglarized a post
office in kellerville illinois after
three weeks on the lam highway patrol
caught him
at the police station when asked about
his occupation ray smirked
and said love her lover was sentenced to
45 months to be served at leavenworth
prison in kansas
over that period rey was noted as being
a well-behaved convict who
furthered his education by taking
classes in typing english spanish and
bakery he was offered a spot
in the honor farm for model prisoners
but rey refused on the ground that the
farm was racially integrated he
preferred to stay in the main prison
which was segregated after his release
ray moved to san luis and returned to
his old habits robbing gambling dens and
spending his ill-gotten gains in bars
and brothels on
trips to mexico and canada by this stage
ray had become quite the competent felon
so much so that in the summer of 1959 he
pulled a string of 12 burglaries but
rey's good streak couldn't go on forever
and he was arrested yet again on october
10th 1959. the sentence he received
on march the 17th of the following year
was a harsh one due to his recidivism
the judge dealt him 20 years to be
served in the missouri state
penitentiary
also known as jeff city
in november 1961 ray staged his first
attempted prison break using a makeshift
ladder but the contraption gave way and
he crashed into the prison
courtyard for the following three years
ray kept a low profile but
he was no model convict he dealt in
contraband bookmaking and dealing
amphetamines smuggled him by
brothers john and jerry the time spent
at jeff city accentuated ray's racist
views he frequently got into fights with
black convicts and guards he began
planning a move to rhodesia which he
believed did not have a black population
john and jerry later testified that
james never expressed hatred for martin
luther king
he simply disliked all african americans
but according to fellow convicts rey had
pondered the idea of killing the
reverend for money
red theorized that if the civil rights
leader was to enact
economic boycotts then business owners
may pay for his murder
so was there such a business leader's
plot
in 1976 the house select committee on
assassinations discovered a group that
may have wanted king dead and they may
have crossed paths with rey
at jeff city this was according to
russell g barr the saint louis criminal
real estate developer john kaufman had
introduced buyers to john sutherland a
wealthy
segregationist lawyer who had offered 50
000 to kill king buyers had refused but
the missouri contract may have made its
way to jeff city
and reached rey's ears both buyers and
kaufman had connections within the
prison including the resident doctor
another convict d.l mitchell
claimed rey had tried to involve him in
an assassination plan against king
a contract worth fifty thousand dollars
the lure of such a payday
may have been the reason for the next
escape attempt in march of 1966 rey
tried once again to scale the walls of
jeff city and was again caught in the
act
at the following trial ray pleaded
temporary insanity which
prompted a psychiatric evaluation the
report noted that he had an iq of 105
slightly above average
he exhibited no evidence of psychosis
but was a sociopathic personality
antisocial type with anxiety and
depressive features
rey was returned to prison where in late
1966 and early 1967 he was assigned to
the prison bakery
where he began planning his next
[Music]
breakout
james el rey's next breakout attempt
took place on april 23 1967. ray hid
inside a container
used to carry bread throughout the
prison two accomplices then loaded the
container onto a truck taking the bread
outside of jeff city at the first stop
rey
jumped out of the truck and took off
back in jail his competitors told a
prison informant that rey was still
inside
this resulted in two days of internal
searches giving time for ray to make his
getaway five or six weeks after the
escape
james met with his brothers john and
jerry in chicago jerry later testified
before the u.s senate that
the ray boys had discussed several
money-making enterprises ranging from
kidnapped to
shooting pornographic movies eventually
though james revealed an explicit detail
that he was planning on killing martin
luther king
jerry disagreed commenting that there
couldn't be any real money in killing a
black man
even one as famous as king where there
was money though was in robbing banks
allegedly on july 13th james and john
robbed a bank in their hometown of alton
two days later james was in montreal
canada now going by the alias eric
starbo gold by his own account he had
befriended raul a shady character of
apparent spanish or latino descent
investigators were never able to confirm
his existence ray needed
a clean canadian passport and identity
and his
new friend offered to help in exchange
ray had to help roll by smuggling
unidentified packages
probably narcotics south of the border
ray did a good job so raul made a new
offer james had to relocate to alabama
and smuggle weapons into mexico from
there
rel promised him safe travel documents a
new car and a paycheck of twelve
thousand dollars having accepted the
offer rey moved back to the u.s
he first met with jerry in chicago again
mentioning the possibility of killing dr
king for money by the end of august 1967
james was living in birmingham alabama
as we've learned he had bought a white
mustang and would eventually take
dancing and bartending lessons
he also frequented between two and nine
psychologists with expertise in
hypnotism
looking at how to improve his memory and
social skills ray also spent some of his
spare time
advocating for presidential candidate
george wallace an outspoken
segregationist
according to an fbi report his support
of wallace even got him into a racial
argument followed by a mugging outside a
bar
he also contacted the ultra-conservative
john birch society asking for
information on moving to rhodesia
finally in march of 1968 he underwent
some minor plastic surgery for his nose
before
leaving l.a in his white mustang after a
short stay in new orleans he moved to
selma alabama on march 22nd
according to rey's own declarations to
author william bradford hugh this
is when he started stalking martin
luther king jr the stalker moved from
selma to montgomery birmingham and
finally atlanta georgia at the end of
the month
he had purchased the model 760 rifle on
the 3rd of april
ray checked in at the rebel motel in
memphis on the 4th
ray left the rebel before 1pm at some
point between 3 and 3 30 pm the 30 year
old mr willard registered at the brewer
rooming house
in sight of the lorraine motel in an
interview with writer hugh
ray claimed that it was raul who checked
in as willard but in a later letter he
admitted that it was he and only he who
had registered at the lodging house
between 3 30 and 5 pm ray bought a pair
of binoculars and then returned to his
room
5b he then moved to the shared bathroom
on the floor from which he could enjoy a
better view of the lorraine motel at 6pm
patrolman richmond could clearly see
reverend king
as he stood on a balcony and then came
the shot
immediately after the shot rang out
through memphis ray left the building
dropped the rifle and sped away in his
mustang on the 5th of april he abandoned
his car in atlanta and
boarded a bus heading to canada which he
reached by the 6th on the 8th he
started the process of acquiring a
canadian passport first he went to a
public library search newspapers from
1932 and picked two names from the birth
notices
then he applied for duplicate birth
certificates for both names taking care
to rent two separate rooms to be
provided as residents addresses
having obtained a duplicate birth
certificate for the alias raymond george
snyde
he asked a travel agent to handle the
request for a new passport this was
issued on april the 24th let's go back
to the fbi investigation now
agents have discovered rey's identity
and movements but his trail had gone
cold they proceeded to
question rey's fellow inmates in
missouri who told them that he planned
to get a canadian passport
following that clue the bureau contacted
the royal canadian mounted police for
help asking them to
review all passports issued after ray's
escape from jeff city
the mounties obliged and on june the
first they identified a passport issued
on the 24th of april 1968. it was in the
name of raymond george snide but the man
in the photo
looked like ray the application had been
filed by a travel agency in toronto by
the same agency
mr snyde had bought a round-trip ticket
to london departing on may the 6th and
returning on may
21st now it was scotland yard's turn to
step in they found that on the 7th snide
had
exchanged his ticket with a fair to
lisbon portugal lisbon police confirmed
that snyde aka james r
ray had in fact landed in lisbon on the
7th he had tried to secure passage to
angola but
then had flown back to london on the
17th on june the 8th james el rey was
finally arrested in heathrow airport as
he was about to leave for belgium
apparently
his ultimate goal was to join a
mercenary force
[Music]
on march 10 1969 james l ray knowingly
and voluntarily pleaded guilty to the
first degree murder
of dr martin luther king jr he also
signed a stipulation confessing to
firing the fatal shot in exchange for
his plea rey was sentenced to 99 years
in prison
instead of the death sentence so a case
cleanly closed after a swift
investigation
well kind of ray later recanted his
confession giving contrasting accounts
of the events of april 4th
in one version related to author william
hugh he claimed that it was raul the
mysterious smuggler who had
actually fired the shot all rey had done
was buy the rifle and drive the mustang
after the hit
of which he was completely unaware in
another version rey alleged being the
fall guy in an fbi conspiracy
in this account he made no mention of
raul in a later statement ral was back
in the picture the criminal had asked
ray to wait in the mustang while he was
meeting with a gun runner as ray waited
for all he realized the tires were blow
on pressure and drove to a service
station at 6 pm
when ray returned he found the area
swarmed by police and drove off
only later did he find out the king had
been shot in the years following his
arrest all the way up to his death on
april 23 1998 rey had repeatedly
reasserted
that he was innocent and while total
innocence is fairly unbelievable
there are enough conspiracy crumbs to at
least raise a bit of an eyebrow
for instance in 1976 the house select
committee on assassinations chaired by
representative louis stokes heard
evidence of how director of the fbi j
edgar hoover had ordered extensive
surveillance and even sabotage actions
against dr king these actions were
motivated by personal animus as
well as the unfounded claims of
communist complicity
the select committee re-examined
evidence of king's assassination and the
department of justice ordered a review
of the subsequent investigation the
final report of chief counsel robert
blakey
theorized that rey may have
co-conspirators the shootings may have
been part of a plot to collect a 50 000
bounty offered by supporters of george
wallace but blakey admitted that there
was no evidence confirming the
conspiracy nor suggesting government
involvement
in the following years rey's conspiracy
claims were backed by his attorney
william f pepper and much more notably
by the king family itself
pepper a civil rights lawyer staged a
mock televised trial in 1993 in which
the jury found rey not guilty
over the years he's authored three books
outlining his theories which we'll try
to
oversimplify here the vast alleged
conspiracy was masterminded by fbi
director hoover and his
assistant clyde tolson but it also
involved the mafia the army special
forces the memphis police department and
the missouri prison authorities the
latter had identified james r ray as a
promising
patsy since his time at jeff city the
mafia had then sent the shady roll to
manipulate him then on the day of the
killing the fatal shot had been fired by
a sniper
of the memphis police among the many
witnesses backing these allegations
pepper had identified lloyd jow as owner
of a restaurant facing the motel
where king had died jaws claimed that he
had hidden the murder weapon behind his
bar
and raoul had later disposed a bit
pepper also identified the infamous raul
allegedly an auto worker from yonkers
new york
pepper's claims were taken seriously by
the department of justice
in 1998 attorney general janet reno
assigned civil rights special counsel
barry kowalski
to reinvestigate the case another
inquiry was opened by the district
attorney office of shelby county
tennessee
led by john campbell in the meantime
pepper and the king family had filed a
civil lawsuit for wrongful death against
lloyd jowers in 1999 a memphis jury
ruled that
the local state and federal governments
were liable for king's death
but the recently deceased ray was not
exonerated as a result and the jury's
verdict was contradicted by the findings
of the kowalski and cambo inquiries
kowalski had found that according to
work records the yonkers suspect could
not have met with rey in 1967 and 1968.
so
he was not raul both kowalski and
campbell agreed that jows had changed
his version too often to be credible
moreover he had been recorded saying
that he would tailor his story for
financial gain
the department of justice's conclusion
was that there was no credible or
reliable evidence that
dr king was killed by conspirators who
framed james l ray campbell admits that
the shooter may have had some help but
he didn't have the fbi the cia the
memphis police
or the mafia and if we're allowed an
opinion then we tend to agree with mr
campbell here if you watch our episode
on dr king
you will learn that hoover and assistant
director sullivan had evidence of
the reverend committing adultery
frequenting prostitutes being present to
a rape and accepting funds from stanley
leveson
a former member of the communist party
usa or rather
they knew that levinson was a former
member but they had failed to inform
attorney general robert kennedy sullivan
had even sent an anonymous letter to dr
king suggesting that he commit suicide
lest his secret personal life be
revealed the fbi leaders had
all the ammo they needed to perform a
total character assassination
so was a bullet really needed
so i really hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe please do check out our
fantastic sponsor keeps who are linked
to below
and thank you for watching
[Music]